Shure: 他没死就行
Shure: As long as he's not dead.
Tasha: 哈哈哈 这个话记住了
Tasha: Hahaha, remember what you said.
Lucia:救命
Lucia: Help!
Katrina: 兄弟情
Katrina: Brotherhood.
Jake:别以为你自己不戴眼镜就
Jake: Don't think just because you don't wear glasses...
Lucia: 对啊 你北京本地
Lucia: Yeah, you're a local in Beijing.
Katrina: 顺点东西走吧
Katrina: Sneak something out.
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah, right.
Shure: 是不是充电宝哈哈哈
Shure: Is it a power bank? Hahaha.
Katrina: 可以顺充电宝吧
Katrina: Can I sneak a power bank?
Katrina: 我正好缺一个
Katrina: I just need one.
Lucia:我也
Lucia: Me too.
Lucia:我们明天走出去
Lucia: We'll walk out tomorrow...
Lucia:把自己用的这个充电宝给他顺走
Lucia: And sneak out the power bank we use.
Katrina: 你要不要带点鸡蛋回去
Katrina: Do you want to take some eggs back?
Tasha:是这个吗
Tasha: Is this it?
Tasha:这有个黑的
Tasha: There's a black one here.
Lucia: 鸡蛋不好带
Lucia: Eggs are hard to carry.
Shure: 有一个大的白的
Shure: There's a big white one.
Katrina: 你端一盒鸡蛋回去吧
Katrina: Take a box of eggs back.
Lucia:对刚好你在北京这个不容易散
Lucia: Yeah, since you're in Beijing, it won't be hard to carry.
Katrina: 还有你的咸鸭蛋
Katrina: And your salted duck eggs.
Tasha:带
Tasha: Take them.
Shure: 哦 还有咸鸭蛋
Shure: Oh, salted duck eggs too?
Shure: 那箱子不好使
Shure: That box doesn't work.
Katrina: 还有酒
Katrina: And wine.
Shure: 我ipad 还没放时去
Shure: I haven't put my iPad yet.
Shure: 酒我带了一瓶
Shure: I brought a bottle of wine.
Katrina: 好家伙
Katrina: Wow.
Tasha: 我天哪
Tasha: Oh my god.
Shure: 然后咖啡给我装好
Shure: And pack my coffee.
Katrina: 瓜分
Katrina: Split it.
Shure: 哦对杨老板还有报销账单我没领
Shure: Oh right, Jake, I haven't claimed the reimbursement yet.
Jake:哎哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:哎 行行行
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Tasha:杨老板什么时候结
Tasha: When will you settle it, Jake?
Tasha:我的也没报呢
Tasha: I haven't claimed mine either.
Jake:好好好给你
Jake: Alright, alright, I'll give it to you.
Lucia:加一
Lucia: Count me in.
Shure: 我们临走前把钱款两清
Shure: Let's settle everything before we leave.
Katrina:  哈哈今今晚算账是吧
Katrina: Haha, are we settling accounts tonight?
Shure: 不当面结清
Shure: Not face to face.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Katrina: 你买了啥呀
Katrina: What did you buy?
Katrina: 他屋子好像也没买啥
Katrina: It looks like you didn't buy much for your room.
Shure: 我屋子里没买啥
Shure: I didn't buy much for my room.
Shure: 我吃饭点了
Shure: I ordered food.
Katrina: 你帮我点
Katrina: You ordered for me?
Katrina: 点外卖了是吗
Katrina: Did you order takeout?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 来帮我摁个计算器家人们
Shure: Help me with the calculator, guys.
Tasha:你等会帮我也摁一下
Tasha: Can you help me with it later?
Shure: 好的
Shure: Sure.
Tasha:算了你报吧
Tasha: Forget it, just tell me.
Tasha:我来帮你加
Tasha: I'll help you add it up.
Shure: 首先139块8
Shure: First, 139.8.
Lucia: 没事
Lucia: No problem.
Tasha:139.8
Tasha: 139.8
Shure的女友:那个点8也要算进来
Shure: Make sure to count the .8 too.
Shure: 去加94
Shure: Add 94.
Katrina: 没有 四舍五四舍算客气了
Katrina: No need, rounding off is fine.
Shure: 22块5毛7
Shure: 22.57
Tasha:加
Tasha: Got it.
Tasha:22.5毛7
Tasha: 22.57
Lucia:那个7
Lucia: That .7
Shure: 加40.8
Shure: Add 40.8
Tasha:40.8
Tasha: 40.8
Shure: 加96
Shure: Add 96.
Tasha:96
Tasha: 96.
Shure: 加49块5毛2
Shure: Add 49.52
Tasha:49.5毛2
Tasha: 49.52
Shure: 啊没有了
Shure: That's it.
Tasha:442.69
Tasha: 442.69
Jake:好行
Jake: Alright, got it.
Shure: 然后还有等一下
Shure: And also wait a second.
Jake:还有摸个0吧
Jake: Add a zero.
Jake:40 哈哈哈
Jake: 40, hahaha.
Jake:摸个0 40 哈哈哈
Jake: Add a zero, 40, hahaha.
Tasha:你怎么不说0.69嘞
Tasha: Why don't you say 0.69?
Lucia: 0.69
Tasha:摸个头吧
Tasha: Pat my head.
Shure: 看看这就是资本主义的压榨
Shure: See, this is the exploitation of capitalism.
Shure: 家人们我们要
Shure: Guys, we need to
Tasha:警惕
Tasha: Be vigilant.
Shure: 警惕
Shure: Be vigilant.
Lucia: 放心吧录下来了
Lucia: Don't worry, it's recorded.
Tasha:我都不敢把我的账单发给他看了
Tasha: I don't even dare to show him my bill.
Lucia:我也
Lucia: Me neither.
Tasha:我这有2,000多的账要报
Tasha: I've got over 2,000 worth of bills to submit.
Shure: 啊34块9毛8
Shure: Ah, 34.98.
Tasha:34.9毛8
Tasha: 34.98.
Shure: 还有一个咖啡豆钱
Shure: And there's a charge for coffee beans.
Tasha:咖啡豆
Tasha: Coffee beans.
Shure: 咖啡豆是
Shure: The coffee beans are...
Lucia:我觉得我们天天在这演群口相声
Lucia: I feel like we're performing a comedy sketch every day.
Shure: 148
Shure: 148.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha:148的咖啡豆
Tasha: 148 for coffee beans.
Jake:这么整呢
Jake: How is this possible?
Jake:假的吧
Jake: Is it fake?
Shure: 嗯是真的
Shure: No, it's real.
Jake:哈哈哈嗯
Jake: Hahaha, yeah.
Shure: 它两包起卖主要是花了这么多钱
Shure: They only sell in packs of two, so it costs this much.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Right.
Jake:总共这么多钱
Jake: Total that much.
Jake:对 好 你是谁
Jake: Okay, who are you?
Shure: 我是哈哈哈
Shure: I'm... hahaha.
Shure: 没事咱咱扫码就行
Shure: No problem, we just scan the code.
Tasha:哈哈哈哦
Tasha: Hahaha, oh.
Shure: 二维码收款ok
Shure: QR code payment, okay.
Tasha:来帮我加一下
Tasha: Help me add it up.
Jake:等会等会
Jake: Hold on, hold on.
Jake:多少钱 625点
Jake: How much? 625.
Shure: 哎 摸个零吧
Shure: Hey, round it off.
Shure: 625就行了
Shure: 625 is fine.
Jake:哎
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 大方吗杨老板
Shure: Generous, Jake?
Jake:哎是挺好
Jake: Yeah, it's pretty good.
Shure: 给你省了1/100新币 哈哈哈
Shure: Saved you 1/100 of a new dollar. Hahaha.
Shure: ok
Shure: Okay.
Tasha:你怎么不帮我啊
Shure: 啊
Tasha:我靠
Jake:来互摁是吧
Shure: ok
Jake:来 摁一下
Tasha:烤箱30
Lucia:你看这就是单次博弈的坏处
Lucia:你们俩要是经常互相摁的话
Lucia:双方就会
Jake:啊就有默契是吧
Lucia:不是开始胡说八道了
Jake:对对对
Tasha:30烤箱加24跑腿
Shure: 24
Lucia: 因为很多次就建立起
Tasha:装修房间493
Lucia: 一个多次博弈模型
Shure: 496
Tasha:加25的地毯
Shure: 25地毯钱
Shure: 25 for the carpet
Tasha:加达美乐点餐220
Tasha: 220 for the Domino's order
Shure: 220加
Shure: 220 plus
Tasha:跑腿16
Tasha: 16 for delivery
Shure: 16加
Shure: 16 plus
薇:盒马702
Tasha: 702 for Hema
Shure: 哈哈 哦
Shure: Haha, oh
Jake:我草哈哈哈
Jake: Oh my gosh, hahaha
Shure: 噢 盒马
Shure: Oh, Hema
Shure: 都让人家付的
Shure: She paid for everything
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah
Tasha:厨房用纸10块
Tasha: 10 bucks for kitchen paper
Shure: 10块
Shure: 10 bucks
Tasha:夹板20
Tasha: 20 for the clips
Shure: 20
Tasha:蛋奶油55
Tasha: 55 for the cream
Shure: 55
Tasha:低筋面粉7
Tasha: 7 for the low-gluten flour
Shure: 7
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah
Tasha:麦当劳568
Tasha: McDonald's 568
Shure: 568的麦当劳
Shure: McDonald's for 568
Katrina: 麦当劳也是你点的
Katrina: You ordered McDonald's too
Tasha:跑腿12.6
Tasha: Delivery fee 12.6
Tasha:跑腿15
Tasha: Delivery fee 15
Tasha:昨天的披萨点餐169今天中午的饭
Tasha: Yesterday's pizza order 169, today's lunch
Tasha:说吧
Tasha: Go ahead
Shure: 2,366块6
Shure: 2,366.6
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow
Tasha:好
Tasha: Okay
Shure: 没没算错吧应该
Shure: I hope I didn't mess up the calculations
Tasha:不知道你啊
Tasha: I don't know about you
Tasha:你不要坑我
Tasha: Don't mess with me
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Jake:你你你坑的不一定是你吧
Jake: You, you, you might not be the one being messed with
Shure: 哈哈哈我再再来一次
Shure: Hahaha, I'll do it again
Shure: 再来一次
Shure: Do it again
Shure: 我怕
Shure: I'm scared
Tasha:烤箱30
Tasha: Oven 30
Shure: 30
Tasha:跑腿24
Tasha: Delivery fee 24
Shure: 24
Tasha:装饰房间493
Tasha: Room decor 493
Shure: 493
Katrina: 咱不需要给他贴那个订单截图吗
Katrina: Don't we need to attach the order screenshot?
Lucia: 再来一块
Lucia: Add another one
Shure: 25
Tasha:达美乐220 跑腿16
Tasha: Domino's 220, delivery fee 16
Lucia: 听起来好像不是很用的样子
Lucia: Sounds like it's not very useful
Tasha:盒马702 厨房用纸10块 夹板20
Tasha: Hema 702, kitchen paper 10, clips 20
Tasha:淡奶油55
Tasha: Whipping cream 55
Tasha:低筋面粉 7
Tasha: Cake flour 7
Lucia:对我在想我装修的那个
Lucia: Yeah, I was thinking about my decoration
Tasha:跑腿12.6
Tasha: Delivery fee 12.6
Katrina: 装修那有很多零零碎碎
Katrina: There are a lot of small bits for decoration
Tasha:昨天的跑腿15
Tasha: Yesterday's delivery fee 15
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right
Katrina: 反正500肯定拉满了我
Katrina: Anyway, 500 is definitely maxed out for me
Tasha:今天中午点餐169
Tasha: Today's lunch order 169
Lucia:我之前算了
Lucia: I calculated it before
Lucia:我好像没到
Lucia: I think I missed it.
Shure: 两遍都是2366
Shure: Both times were 2366.
Lucia:不过过快了
Lucia: But it was too fast.
Jake:两遍都是啊
Jake: Both times, huh?
Jake:行多少
Jake: What's the total?
Shure: 3 2366.6
Shure: 3, 2366.6
Jake:来来来扫扫扫
Jake: Come on, let's scan it.
Tasha:你也扫啊
Tasha: You scan it too.
Jake:对
Jake: Sure.
Tasha:好
Tasha: Alright.
Tasha:谢谢你杨老板
Tasha: Thank you, Jake.
Katrina: 吃大餐去吧
Katrina: Let's go for a big meal.
Jake:写什么论文吃大餐
Jake: What paper? Let's go eat.
Jake:大餐去了
Jake: Big meal it is.
Katrina: 吃大餐去吧
Katrina: Let's go for a big meal.
Katrina: 哈哈带人家吃点好的
Katrina: Haha, take us out for something good.
Tasha:哇
Tasha: Wow.
Jake:哎多多少
Jake: Hey, how much?
Jake:2,000
Jake: 2,000
Shure: 366块6
Shure: 366.6
Jake:366 好
Jake: 366, alright.
Jake:2300
Jake: 2300
Tasha:什么
Tasha: What?
Tasha:呃还少带了一个6
Tasha: Uh, missed a 6.
Tasha:好开始
Tasha: Alright, let's start.
Tasha:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahaha
老板:我靠
Boss: Damn.
Shure: OK
Jake:OK
Jake: OK
Tasha:杨老板到底转了多少
Tasha: Jake, how much did you actually spin?
Tasha:可恶啊哈哈
Tasha: So annoying, haha.
Tasha:他怎么把0加点加上了
Tasha: Why did he add the point?
Tasha:好吧
Tasha: Alright then.
Jake:不应该加上吗
Jake: Shouldn't I add it?
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake:我还缺啥吗
Jake: Am I missing anything?
Tasha:其实我觉得可以加
Tasha: Actually, I think it can be added.
Tasha:哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:加什么
Jake: Add what?
Tasha:加上那个点
Tasha: Add the point.
Jake:再加6分钱是吧
Jake: Add another 6 cents, right?
Shure: 对我的充电宝
Shure: Yeah, for my power bank.
Katrina: 充电宝还分人吗
Katrina: Do power banks belong to specific people?
Katrina: 我们不都随便拿
Katrina: Don't we all just use them?
Shure: 不是我有一个自带的充电宝
Shure: No, I have my own power bank.
Katrina: 哦哦哦哦
Katrina: Oh, oh, okay.
Jake:你还损失了一个充电宝
Jake: You lost a power bank too.
Tasha:哇
Tasha: Wow.
Tasha:算上你这笔钱
Tasha: Count that money too.
Tasha:我这个什么微信收款
Tasha: For my WeChat payments.
Tasha:累积到1万块钱了
Tasha: It's accumulated to 10,000 yuan.
Jake:哦这么真
Jake: Oh, really?
Shure: 然后还有还有什么吗
Shure: And then, is there anything else?
Tasha:好我的报销完毕
Tasha: Alright, my reimbursements are done.
Shure: 这几天的工资没有谈
Shure: We haven't talked about these days' wages.
Jake:哈哈哈好嘞
Jake: Haha, okay.
Jake:你你找找你的充电宝
Jake: You, find your power bank.
Jake:你你找找
Jake: Look for it.
Jake:对总共就两层
Jake: It's just on the second floor.
Shure: 啊这个是我的啊
Shure: Ah, this is mine.
Jake:给他换给他换一个
Jake: Give him a replacement.
Shure: 加上今天一共就是四天工资
Shure: Including today, it's four days of wages.
Katrina: 算上今天
Katrina: Counting today?
Jake:对欠4天
Jake: Yes, four days owed.
Jake:欠4天工资
Jake: Four days of wages.
Jake:然后你你红包抢过吗
Jake: And did you get your red envelope?
Tasha:欠4天工资
Tasha: Four days of wages owed.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Tasha:那我一天没领
Tasha: I didn't get anything for a day.
Jake:你不你第一天抢的红包啊
Jake: Didn't you get the red envelope on the first day?
Shure: 啊昨天我看一下
Shure: Ah, let me check yesterday.
Tasha:是吗
Tasha: Really?
Tasha:到底是从哪天开始算
Tasha: When does it start counting?
Tasha:我也不记得算了
Tasha: I don't remember anymore.
Katrina: 但是我领过一个这种
Katrina: But I did get one.
Katrina: 70的这种
Katrina: A 70 yuan one.
Katrina: 哦我这还有昨天超市的账我去
Katrina: Oh, I still have yesterday's supermarket bill.
Jake:哦这个
Jake: Oh, this.
Jake:来来来我给你给你算算
Jake: Come, let me calculate that for you.
Lucia:这瓜还挺好吃啊
Lucia: This melon is pretty good.
Tasha:我也觉的
Tasha: I think so too.
Lucia:非常的
Lucia: Very much.
Katrina: 我抢了161
Katrina: I grabbed 161.
Katrina: 我靠我抢了3
Katrina: Oh my, I grabbed 3.
Jake:应该是从
Jake: It should be from...
Tasha:你看你
Tasha: Look at you.
Tasha:哎每天整那么花里胡哨自己都忘
Tasha: Hey, you make everything so flashy every day, you even forget it yourself.
Jake:没没忘没有
Jake: No, I didn't forget.
Jake:差点就忘了
Jake: Almost forgot.
Jake:就这个300
Jake: This 300...
Jake:第第一天300是吧
Jake: The first day was 300, right?
Jake:嗯然后第二天157 这算吗
Jake: Yeah, and the second day was 157. Does that count?
Jake:什么嗯
Jake: What? Hmm.
Jake:就是你你157
Jake: Yeah, you had 157.
Jake:哎你143领掉了别的应该没有什么
Jake: And you used up 143, there shouldn't be anything else.
Katrina: 哼
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake:哎还有这个153领掉了是吧
Jake: Oh, and you used up 153 too, right?
Jake:嗯好嘞
Jake: Okay then.
Jake:604 好来扫你
Jake: 604, alright, let's scan you.
Shure: 应该没了
Shure: That should be it.
Shure: 感谢老板
Shure: Thanks, boss.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Tasha:904这是什么
Tasha: 904, what is this?
Shure: 提供打车
Shure: It's for the taxi.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:这是
Jake: This is...
Katrina: 祝大哥顺顺顺什么
Katrina: Wishing big bro good luck with what?
Jake:三 四天 四天的工资
Jake: Three, four days, four days' wages.
Katrina: 顺水
Katrina: Good luck.
Tasha:钱 怎么还有4块呢
Tasha: Why is there 4 yuan left?
Jake:因为他之前摸了个红包
Jake: Because he grabbed a red envelope before.
Shure: 顺山顺水顺财神
Shure: Good luck in the mountains, good luck with money.
Katrina: 顺顺顺顺顺财神
Katrina: Good luck, good luck with money.
Katrina: 呵呵
Katrina: Haha.
Shure: 呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:啥东西啊
Jake: What is that?
Shure: 哦我有钱有钱了
Shure: Oh, I have money now.
Jake:有钱了
Jake: Got money now.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 现在有好多钱
Shure: Now I have a lot of money.
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 再见了杨老板
Shure: Goodbye, Jake.
Shure: 我会想你的
Shure: I'll miss you.
Shure: 啊对
Shure: Ah, right.
Shure的女友:没关系这全是我的
Sister: It's okay, it's all mine.
Katrina: 你们俩咋回去
Katrina: How are you two getting back?
Katrina: 打车还是什么
Katrina: Taking a cab or what?
Shure: 打车 还是有点远打车回去
Shure: Taking a cab, it's a bit far, so we'll take a cab back.
Shure的女友:都行
Sister: Either way.
Katrina: 打车回去多少钱
Katrina: How much is the cab fare?
Shure的女友:不知道好像
Sister: Not sure, I think...
Katrina: 报哈哈哈
Katrina: Report it, hahaha.
Shure: 社个报吗杨老板
Shure: Should we report it, Jake?
Jake:这个也能报
Jake: Yeah, you can report this too.
Shure: 哎呀操打车
Shure: Oh man, taking a cab.
Jake:你先打你先打你先打
Jake: You call first, you call first, you call first.
Shure: OK哎呦我的妈呀
Shure: OK, oh my god.
Jake:打完
Jake: Done calling?
Katrina: 哇回武汉能报吗
Katrina: Wow, can we report the fare back to Wuhan?
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:打车回武汉是吗
Jake: Taking a cab back to Wuhan?
Lucia:哦那我打车回西安
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Katrina: 打车
Katrina: Taking a cab.
Tasha:那我打车回个家
Tasha: Then I'll take a cab home.
Jake:回哪杭州啊
Jake: Going back where? Hangzhou?
Shure: 老板大气
Shure: Jake is so generous.
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:要打车回三亚
Lucia: I want to take a cab back to Sanya.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha:好
Tasha: Alright.
Shure: 我我们把杨老板给榨干了
Shure: We totally drained Jake.
Jake:哈对又惦记又没钱了
Jake: Haha, yeah, thinking about it but no money left.
Alice:什么打车回三亚
Alice: What, taking a cab back to Sanya?
Lucia:嗯 对
Lucia: Yeah, right.
Alice:打车回三亚
Alice: Taking a cab back to Sanya.
Lucia:我 没有没有开玩笑
Lucia: No, no, just kidding.
Tasha:他说打车报销
Tasha: He said the cab fare will be reimbursed.
Alice:什么时候打车
Tasha:现在啊
Tasha: Now?
Jake:明 啊 现在
Jake: Yes, now.
Alice:谁走啊
Alice: Who's leaving?
Jake:他走
Jake: He's leaving.
Alice:我也得走
Alice: I have to leave too.
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Lucia:修硕
Lucia: Shure.
Shure: 我还第一天长安街的半天的工资
Shure: I still have half a day's pay from Chang'an Street on my first day.
Shure: 那个算吗
Shure: Does that count?
Jake:第一天
Jake: The first day?
Shure: 去长安街录像的那个
Shure: The day we filmed on Chang'an Street.
Jake:哎那应该
Jake: Oh, that should...
Shure: XBZ没给我
Shure: XBZ didn't give it to me.
Katrina: 私吞了
Katrina: He pocketed it.
Alice:什么叫把谢老板
Alice: What do you mean by "pocketed it"?
Shure: 给谢彬竹发了
Shure: He sent it to Xie Binzhu.
Alice:什么榨干
Alice: What squeezing?
Katrina: 杨杨老板
Katrina: Jake.
Katrina: 老板名字说怎么工资就别想要了
Katrina: You mention the boss's name, forget about getting paid.
Lucia:就是蟹老板
Lucia: It's like Mr. Krabs.
Tasha:谢老板
Tasha: Mr. Xie.
Lucia:蟹老板
Lucia: Mr. Krabs.
Jake:蟹老板我们做汉堡
Jake: Mr. Krabs, we're making burgers.
Tasha:卖汉堡的
Tasha: Selling burgers.
Jake:哈哈哈 我们一起做汉堡去
Jake: Hahaha, let's go make burgers together.
Shure: 一百
Shure: One hundred.
Shure的女友:你打车了吗
Shure's GF: Did you call a taxi?
Shure: 138块5毛4
Shure: 138.54 yuan.
Alice:你们带伞了吗
Alice: Did you bring an umbrella?
Alice:只有这没下雨
Alice: It's not raining only here.
Alice:朝阳都下了
Alice: It's raining in Chaoyang.
Katrina: 你今天晚上也要走啊
Katrina: Are you leaving tonight too?
Jake:等一下啊
Jake: Wait a moment.
Alice:啊对
Alice: Yeah.
Jake:看一下
Jake: Let me check.
Katrina: 学校有事吗
Katrina: Is there something at school?
Alice:对明天有事
Alice: Yeah, something tomorrow.
Alice:明天不想早起直接在寝室睡
Alice: I don't want to wake up early, so I'll sleep in the dorm.
Katrina: 真好
Katrina: Sounds nice.
Jake:第0天是150
Jake: The first day was 150.
Jake:你你说的是哪一个
Jake: Which one are you talking about?
Shure: 还负一天
Shure: And it's still a day off.
Shure: 你记不记得我提前拿到那个去长安街
Shure: Do you remember I got that thing and went to Chang'an Street early?
Shure: 跟那
Shure: With that...
Alice:所以现在在
Alice: So now at...
Jake:那算150里啊
Jake: That counts as 150, right?
Shure: 那算这个
Shure: Yeah, that counts.
Jake:对对对算150
Jake: Yes, yes, it counts as 150.
Katrina: 对对对算钱呢
Katrina: Yes, yes, let's calculate the money.
Tasha:算工钱
Tasha: Calculate the wages.
Katrina: 他问老板包工头要要清钱在这
Katrina: He asked the boss for the payment here.
Shure: 那就报销一个打车费啦好吧
Shure: Then let's reimburse for the taxi fare, okay?
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Alice:哎我没戴眼镜
Alice: Oh, I forgot my glasses.
Shure: 谢谢老板谢谢老板
Shure: Thank you, boss, thank you.
Jake:别打专车就行
Jake: Just don't take the special car.
Shure: 没有没有没打专车没打专车
Shure: No, no, I didn't take the special car.
Shure: 快车都没敢打
Shure: I didn't even dare to take the fast car.
Shure: 咱打的是特惠
Shure: We took the economy option.
Tasha:拼车啊哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Carpooling, haha.
Alice:呆会我打车能报销吗我比较近
Alice: Can I get reimbursed for my taxi later? I'm pretty close.
Jake:都都可以
Jake: Yes, yes, sure.
Jake:可以没问题
Jake: No problem.
Alice:但我没戴眼镜我现在就要把它卸了
Alice: But I don't have my glasses, I need to take them off now.
Shure: 但是这个打车费有点贵
Shure: But this taxi fare is a bit expensive.
Jake:你可以戴眼镜
Jake: You can wear your glasses.
Shure: 能报吗
Shure: Can it be reimbursed?
Alice:眼镜呢
Alice: Where are my glasses?
Katrina: 为什么多少钱
Katrina: Why, how much was it?
Lucia:多少钱
Lucia: How much?
Tasha:多少钱
Tasha: How much?
Tasha:138块5毛4
Tasha: 138.54 yuan.
Katrina: 小声我以为两开头呢小声
Katrina: Whispering, I thought it started with a two, whispering.
Jake:100也也行吧
Jake: 100 is okay, right?
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh man.
Jake:好说
Jake: It's fine.
Shure: 谢谢老板
Shure: Thank you, boss.
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice:杨老板眼镜在哪
Alice: Jake, where are the glasses?
Shure: 今年啊顶会
Shure: This year, at the top meeting.
Shure: 我感觉靖康的名字要要JKR
Shure: I feel like Jingkang's name should be JKR.
Shure: 这个名字要出现10-10 20次
Shure: This name should appear 10-20 times.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha
Alice:老板眼镜在哪
Alice: Boss, where are the glasses?
Shure: 这不算多吗
Shure: Isn't that a lot?
Shure: 我不太了解这个
Shure: I don't really get this.
Lucia: 我也不太了解
Lucia: I don't really get it either.
Katrina: 算多
Katrina: It's a lot.
Shure: 算多啊
Shure: It's a lot, huh?
Katrina: 直接驳倒了
Katrina: Totally refuted it.
Katrina: 我驳倒都没发生这么多
Katrina: I refuted it and it didn't happen so many times.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Shure: 院长了
Shure: The dean.
Shure: 哈哈哈杨院长
Shure: Hahaha Dean Yang.
Tasha:受不了
Tasha: Can't handle it.
Shure: 哎呦这个名字听着爽爽
Shure: Oh, this name sounds cool.
Alice:所以所以
Alice: So, so...
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
Alice:所以眼镜在哪啊
Alice: So where are the glasses?
Jake:你眼镜
Jake: Your glasses.
Katrina: 那我也来算账
Katrina: Then I'll do the accounting.
Katrina: 我去拿我的笔点点
Katrina: I'll go get my pen to mark it down.
Alice:这个不是我的
Alice: This isn't mine.
Katrina: 点晚饭了吗
Katrina: Did you order dinner?
Jake:你眼镜在
Jake: Your glasses are here.
Lucia:没呢
Lucia: Not yet.
Katrina: 感觉我还是没啥胃口
Katrina: I still don't have much of an appetite.
Alice:打完了吗
Alice: Finished?
Katrina: 吃点西瓜
Katrina: Eat some watermelon.
Alice:我现在要开始拆喽
Alice: I'm going to start unwrapping now.
Katrina: 谢彬竹等一会来
Katrina: Xie Binzhu will come later.
Katrina: 谢彬竹说他要住住你的房间
Katrina: Xie Binzhu says he wants to stay in your room.
Tasha:XBZ让他吃完晚饭再来我们
Tasha: XBZ said he would come after dinner to our place.
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Alice:XBZ晚上还来吗
Alice: Is XBZ still coming tonight?
Shure: 谢彬竹晚上来吗
Shure: Is Xie Binzhu coming tonight?
Tasha:他说他发烧了来换个床
Tasha: He said he has a fever and needs to change beds.
Katrina: 他说他陪他过来唠嗑
Katrina: He said he would come over to chat.
Katrina: 哈哈哈我说修硕走谁跟我玩
Katrina: Hahaha I said, Shure, who will play with me?
Alice:不是明天中午就结束吗今天晚上来还干嘛
Alice: Isn't it ending tomorrow at noon? Why come tonight?
Tasha:他说他过来唠
Tasha: He said he came over to chat.
Tasha:他说他过来唠嗑
Tasha: He said he came over to chit-chat.
Lucia:他来唠嗑
Lucia: He came over to chit-chat.
Katrina: 嗯他他们应该要帮忙拆东西
Katrina: Yeah, they probably came to help take things apart.
Katrina: 董叉叉也问我们什么时候退房来着
Katrina: Jack also asked when we're checking out.
Alice:哦是拆这些
Alice: Oh, to take these apart.
Katrina: 唠嗑指顺便
Katrina: Chatting means doing it along the way.
Jake:不是谢彬竹
Jake: Not Xie Binzhu.
Jake:谢彬竹他到底发不发烧啊
Jake: Is Xie Binzhu having a fever or not?
Shure: 他发着 他确实是发着 发着
Shure: He does, he really does, he does.
Jake:他发着就特适合聊天
Jake: If he has a fever, it's perfect for chatting.
Tasha:他啊
Tasha: Him, huh?
Tasha:他太想聊天了
Tasha: He really wants to chat.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Katrina: 他一直想套我的八卦你知道吗
Katrina: He keeps trying to get gossip from me, you know?
Katrina: 昨天晚上没问完就走了
Katrina: He left last night without finishing.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure: 30 37度7还在外面坚持
Shure: At 37.7 degrees, he's still hanging in there.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:这冷风中是吧 哈哈哈
Jake: In this cold wind, right? Hahaha.
Shure: 他今天应该比昨天还热
Shure: He should be even hotter today than yesterday.
Alice:还是充电宝
Alice: Still like a power bank.
Shure: 我觉得保持点距离
Shure: I think we should keep some distance.
Katrina: 对我也感觉
Katrina: Yeah, I feel the same.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Katrina: 如果我也头疼怎么办
Katrina: What if I get a headache too?
Jake:那那不用保持距离
Jake: Then we don't need to keep a distance.
Jake:那我们跟你保持距离
Jake: We'll keep a distance from you.
Jake:跟你们俩保持距离
Jake: Keep a distance from both of you.
Katrina: 我昨天真的是
Katrina: Yesterday, I really...
Katrina: 要么就是不能加那个青提还是怎么的
Katrina: Maybe I shouldn't have added the green grapes or something.
Alice:怎么没充电宝
Alice: Why no power bank?
Jake:充电宝可能有吧
Jake: There might be a power bank.
Lucia:让我看看
Lucia: Let me see.
Jake:充电宝 拔吧拔吧
Jake: Power bank, unplug it.
Lucia: 全部
Lucia: All of it.
Katrina: 那我直接算钱算了
Katrina: Then I'll just calculate the cost directly.
Katrina: 就不给他发订单截图
Katrina: I won't send him the order screenshot.
Lucia: 109  32
Lucia: 109, 32.
Shure: 杨老板太大气
Shure: Jake is so generous.
Lucia: 32
Shure: 后来 杨老板像 多多财运
Shure: Then Jake was like, "More and more wealth."
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Shure: 他老板说他请的助手太混了
Shure: His boss said the assistant he hired was too lazy.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Shure: 但杨老板你看我给你省了500块钱房屋装修费
Shure: But Jake, look, I saved you 500 bucks on renovation costs.
Jake:哎那确实那确实
Jake: Yes, that's true.
Tasha:省怎么省呢
Tasha: How did you save it?
Lucia:他没装修啊
Lucia: He didn't renovate at all.
Jake:省成这样省成这样
Jake: Saved this much, saved this much.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 那咱是不是省了吗
Shure: So didn't we save?
Jake:省啊省啊
Jake: Yes, we did.
Shure: 就是因为我本来
Shure: It's because I originally...
Tasha:你就说花的值不值吗值
Tasha: Are you saying it was worth the cost?
Jake:值  哈哈哈
Jake: It was. Hahaha
Shure: 就是数据集这要保证多样性
Shure: The data set needs to ensure diversity.
Lucia: 这这玩意怎么加啊
Lucia: How do you add this?
Shure: 就是有人需要装修有人不需要
Shure: Some people need renovation, some don't.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Shure: 你下次给我住毛坯房就行
Shure: Next time, just give me an unfinished house.
Shure: 只要工资到位
Shure: As long as the salary is paid.
Tasha:给给
Tasha: Sure, sure.
Shure: 倒挂着住也没关系
Shure: I don't mind living upside down.
Jake:那行下次就这么定了
Jake: Alright, let's settle it next time.
Tasha:那个8块钱一天的那个
Tasha: The one that's 8 bucks a day.
Jake:啊富塞倒碑塔
Jake: Ah, the Fousey Tao Tower.
Lucia: 啊富塞倒 ok
Lucia: Ah, Fousey Tao, okay.
Lucia:你这个研究逐渐变态在下去阴塞道去了
Lucia: Your research is getting weirder.
Shure: 塞道那是什么鬼
Shure: 我要倒立
Shure: I need to do a handstand.
Shure: 怎么着也得500一天吧
Shure: It should be at least 500 a day, right?
Lucia: 哈哈哈你真能倒立这么久吗
Lucia: Hahaha, can you really do a handstand that long?
Tasha:我靠那还是让他住房吧
Tasha: Oh my, just let him stay in a house then.
Shure: 我比房子都贵
Shure: I'm more expensive than the house.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Katrina:  董叉叉问我什么时候离开
Katrina: Jack asked me when I am leaving.
Jake: 问你什么时候离开
Jake: Asked when you are leaving?
Katrina:  他说靖康应该要在你们后收拾东西
Katrina: He said Jingkang should pack up after you guys.
Katrina:  他他是不是要过来帮忙
Katrina: Is he coming over to help?
Katrina:  所以他要协调自己的时间是吗
Katrina: So he needs to coordinate his time, right?
Jake: 他可能是吧
Jake: Maybe he does.
Jake: 他为什么不问我呢
Jake: Why doesn't he ask me?
Tasha:我哈哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Katrina:  有道理哈
Katrina: Makes sense.
Lucia: 087.44
Katrina:  我要帮他看一下
Katrina: I'll help him take a look.
Katrina:  卧槽这这小狐狸真就没了
Katrina: Whoa, this little fox is really gone.
Lucia: 29 7天 29 7.2
Lucia: 29, 7 days, 29, 7.2
Lucia: 哎 我靠
Lucia: Oh my god.
Shure: 好我可以定酒店了
Shure: Okay, I can book the hotel now.
Jake: 有钱啦
Jake: We've got money now.
Shure: 修 我手机呢
Shure: Hey, where's my phone?
Shure: 你手机在这呢
Shure: Your phone is here.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Shure的女友:谢谢你
Shure: Thank you.
Shure: 我们是定两天就好了吗
Shure: Should we book for just two days?
Shure的女友:你啊
Shure: You?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Jake: 吃个西瓜压压惊
Jake: Let's have some watermelon to calm down.
Tasha: 谁下呢哈哈哈
Tasha: Who's going down, haha
Shure: 怎么抖了呢杨老板你手
Shure: Why is your hand shaking, Jake?
Lucia: 加
Lucia: Plus
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Lucia: 算完了
Lucia: Done calculating.
Jake:什么东西呀
Jake: What's that?
Shure: 好惨呢
Shure: It's so miserable.
Alice:这窗帘真的很像婚纱的质地啊
Alice: These curtains really look like wedding dress fabric.
Alice:所以做婚纱为什么不能用窗帘
Alice: So why can't wedding dresses be made from curtains?
Lucia: 可能说亲肤吧哈哈
Lucia: Maybe it's because of skin-friendliness, haha.
Tasha: 可能用的是一块布
Tasha: Maybe it's just a piece of cloth.
Tasha: 但是为了显肤
Tasha: But to show off the skin.
Alice: 我以为他走了
Alice: I thought he left.
Lucia: 洗一下
Lucia: Wash it.
Alice:有一股工厂的味
Alice: It smells like a factory.
Lucia: 对 新的这些布料
Lucia: Yeah, these new fabrics.
Lucia: 没事 不用洗了
Lucia: It's okay, no need to wash it.
Alice: 让刘婷拿着玩吧
Alice: Let Liu Ting play with it.